pas
[Musique]
la crèche départemental les petits
princes à saint denis organisé une fête
pour célébrer la fin de l'année au
programme de l'après-midi divers
ateliers tels qu'un spectacle de
marionnettes ou encore un accueil et de
bulles géantes
pour certains il s'agissait du dernier
jour de crèche avant la rentrée à
l'école
un moment de partage et d'émotion entre
parents enfants et professionnels
aujourd'hui c'est une fête pour clôturer
l'année l'année les enfants qui vont
partir à l'école
donc voilà ils ont passé trois ans avec
nous et là bas c'est le départ pour
l'école c'est toujours les tout-petits
s'épanouissent et sociabilise au contact
deux autres enfants ce qui facilite le
passage en école a pu vraiment à voir ce
lien avec la crèche et les parents est
vraiment en profiter de tous les moments
importants et la réfection y paraît car
un petit pansement son dernier jour
aujourd'hui donc oui effectivement il a
été heureux très et à lyon parce qu'il
est rentré de ses quatre mois et donc je
pense que ça va beaucoup permis de
pouvoir mieux s'exprimer au niveau
national élite et caetera et pour
surtout la rentrée à davos exception
c'était très important je pense en
départ à l'école pour les plus grands et
de nouveaux petits qui eux intégreront
la crèche des p'tits princes dès la
rentrée du mois d'août
[Musique]